i am here to talk about something that
i'm extremely
passionate about i love food and i love
certain dishes we all have our favorite
cravings
but can you make them in a different way
where they're actually
healthy and good for you well here to
help
with that dilemma and solve it is
renowned personal chef
jennifer o'fear
okay you are making something that we
all
love and crave which is lasagna
but let's face it lasagna is a heavy
dish
yes it can be and you found a way to
make it
not only light delicious but healthy
yes so what i've created for you i heard
you
love comfort food i love comfort food
which is why
i'm on such a mission to find
alternatives because i don't want to eat
diet food all the time and it's going to
make me rebel
and it won't make me happy no i want to
eat the foods i love
but i want to find invented ways to make
them so this
powerhouse lasagna is basically
greens greens greens and we're going to
use
zucchini as the sheets
which i will say i don't think there's
anything more
on planet earth that i hate it really
ruffles my f
feathers than zoodles don't you dare
tell me
that a zoodle is a noodle you can
spiralize your way right out of my face
with that
i don't agree i don't like it all right
maybe it's just my opinion and other
people love it
but it's because it changes the texture
of the vegetables so much yes but when
zucchini is served more like an
eggplant it's my favorite vegetable it's
so delicious
and we have the sheets here
and we're gonna use our mandolin okay
and we're going to put it be careful
you're going to do a glove
okay oh yeah but i also i mean
as chefs we learn you want to splay
up your fingers okay all right
as you slide but you have the glove so
let's take our zucchini i'm just going
to cut off the top
yep and the bottom okay this is kind of
like my first time working with a
mandolin
okay so it always scared me
it should scare you but we're gonna i'm
like i love zucchini i don't want to
lose a finger over it okay
so comment palm it
splayed fingers up and go slow
you don't need to go fast i do i
everything i know
slower okay this is oh wait i'm like a
jack rabbit
see so you're gonna get these like
little sheets
oh my god
zucchini sheets and then we're gonna lay
them down
on a sheet tray beautiful and then a
little bit of oil
olive oil salt and pepper goes in the
oven and then we come
to this beautiful car sheets
noodles this is how i want a noodle
this zucchini noodle i love so
we have our lasagna okay we have sauce
some zucchini layers our powerhouse
green mixture
which is again lots of spinach kale you
could use whatever
greens you want and they're frozen or
fresh
these are frozen i love the frozen
aspect too because
anything that's really pantry friendly
is just
much more accessible for people when
everyone's like you got to go to the
farmer's market i'm like okay
well goody for you no no so we put the
powerhouse
cheese layer more sauce more zucchini
some mozzarella and now we're going to
finish it off
we're going to lay the strips on top all
right i don't think i need the gloves
for that no i don't think you'll i don't
think unless this zucchini is a piranha
i'm safe
no no sharp teeth on the zucchini no
and what's great also is once you
assemble this you can freeze it
and then bake it later oh you can freeze
it yes
okay now we're gonna take our sauce
and we're gonna finish our lasagna
just spread it on top see normally i'd
be spreading the
real lasagna all over my butt
because that's where it's going to end
up anyway
okay now we're sprinkling the moths now
we have our umami
flavor here our parmesan there is
nothing more
wonderful on planet earth than
parmigiano
and this is parmigiano reggiano okay
so now okay and now it goes into an oven
all right and i'm gonna walk to the oven
and pull our lasagna out how long in the
oven at what temp
uh we do 400 for
about 30 to 45 minutes you want
a big window 15 minute well i'll i'll
give you some visual cues
you're going to have some um
sauce bubbling in the corners and the
cheese is going to be brown
and yummy on top
okay i mean no one
doesn't want to stick their face in them
and the fact that it's healthy yes like
well it's healthy i mean there are fat
there is fat in there but it's all whole
foods
nothing is processed it's basically what
our grandparents would have eaten
100 years ago great-grandparents you
know so i like to think of it
that way well i thank you so much for
bringing my passion to life which is
a healthy alternative of an indulgent
food
and it's like nobody wants plain jane
diet food no
we want to indulge but there's a way to
do it and
thanks to you jennifer you've shown us
how i'm cutting right into this baby
ready
eddie oh my god i'm so
[Applause]
[Music]
excited
you